all right what's your next what's the
next tangent the next tangent is the
funniest and most bizarre Japanese
advertisements
I'm surprised we never talked about this
I saw one the other day right I don't
know what it was promoting okay but it
was like a cow that was styled like
josuke from JoJo we had like the
pompadour it was like a delinquent and
then the cow walks up to these two
delinquents on the train is like leave
those old people alone and they all
people take a seat and then it cuts to
the product I don't know what they are I
don't know what they are promoting and
what the message was
that definitely sounds like a Japanese
side I have no idea and then I think it
was like some kind of milk based instant
soup it was something right yeah there's
a lot of weird Japanese eyes yeah I mean
like you know I think what's funny is
that like you know in the west there's
that like whole stereotype of like oh
Japanese ads are some of like the most
wackiest they don't make any [__]
sense type of ads and yeah there's
certainly a lot of them but like I think
a lot of people have this weird image
that that's the majority of ads in Japan
whereas there are some normal ads if you
have volumes are boring they love Chimes
still a lot of times yeah they love
Jingles like Jingles they push Jingles
so hard one uh one ad that I recently
saw that I thought was really funny uh
was uh you know obviously because like
chainsaw man it's still massive in Japan
uh I saw this huge like Banner
advertisement in one of the train
stations and it was just like the like
95 of this Banner was just makima's face
and I've seen this one and I was like
what the [__] is this yeah and I read it
and it's a an ad for a recruitment
company I basically said I want you to
be mine but it was like it was written
in like macular style of like speech and
it's like I want you to be mine come to
this recruitment company I'm like that
is so Giga brain I hate how I effective
I know that ad is yeah you know just by
putting [__] makima's face and being
like you can work under for me yeah you
can be mine you can be mine I'm like
[__] can I have my own makima in my life
man
so sometimes they're like gigabrain
other times it's just like uh you know I
think a lot of the wins ones that I've
seen where it's just like that's kind of
unnecessary is that they take like a
celebrity or a comedian or whatever yeah
they put them into like a weird [__]
like body suit yeah they have a lot of
weird surrealist type of commercials
right yeah what the [__] is happening
yeah like there's this commercial that's
been playing all the time like every
taxi I've gone through recently where
it's these people on stage dancing or
something like that and it's like this
absurdist nightmare where they slowly
turn into puppets or something like that
and then like one person turns into a
puppet but everyone keeps on dancing and
then slowly the entire crew is just like
a [__] is is
a plastic puppet or something like that
and I'm like this is this is the stuff
of nightmares actually what are you
trying to promote here I'm so confident
like taxi ads are like some of my
favorite because it's like they're
clearly trying to like make it you know
interesting and like kind of visually
appealing and like visually like fun
happy times yay but all the ads are just
like join up with this Cloud management
system for your company they have that
one ad that runs in every single taxi
and it's the translation uh device oh
yeah yeah and then there's always like
these quizzes yeah the taxi that's like
yeah
it'll be like a Japanese phrase and
it'll be like what's the answer in
English and be like it's very nice to
meet you it's lovely to meet you and
it's like I'm like pressing it like
I know this one
I saw this other the other day in a taxi
that was just it was promoting this
mattress right yeah that was meant to be
so stable that uh and how they tried to
promote it was they got someone to jump
on the mattress with like a glass a red
wine but
I noticed in the advertisements
um they had the shot where the sky jumps
on this kind of suit jumps on right I
mean the glass is like like in front of
him in frame right uh but also in frame
was the fact that this glass was on top
of a towel that was opaque and and you
could see the shot where this guy jumps
on the uh jumps on this mattress he like
paddocks for a bit looks at the glass
and then just smiles and I'm just like
you sneaky [__] how many takes
how many [__] tastes for this girl
man
it's basically like this product for the
suite in Japan this is very long it's
like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they
told like a story through like 10 ads
where the guy like left his wife and was
gay or something yeah something like
that yeah it was really good oh that was
that was pretty they do a lot of those
actually like SoftBank uh has had this
like long running like story arc in
their advertisements where it's like
they get back uh they get like uh
characters from like Japanese folklore
and like uh put them in situations where
it's like oh you know uh momotaro would
you like uh uh I wanna I wanna way to be
able to contact you when I make it to
the island of the Devils well why not
try SoftBank and it's and this ad series
I guess has been going off like 10 plus
years oh my God and they're still making
it these like recurring characters so
much so I think I went to a soft bank
the other day and I saw that they were
selling much
of these characters make sense why not
why not yeah and I'm like who
who is buying this
yeah SoftBank employees I mean I I also
noticed that a lot of Japanese strategy
when it comes to advertisement is can we
make this thing an anime character have
you have you noticed every time you like
every time I've gone to like a new
prefecture or something oh yeah and they
try to promote whatever that prefecture
is famous for it's like really bad yeah
they're called yeah but um every
prefector or like City or whatever has
this like kind of mascot type thing
usually you know they they may also make
like a giant [__] uh you know some of
them are so [__] ugly yeah and
they're so bad yeah the designs yeah I
like uh
I think it's
Hokkaido uh they have which is the the
bear with the the melon on his head and
I'm like it's just a [__] black bear
with a melon on his head this got
nothing to do with Hokkaido yeah I've
I've started to know this because uh I
went to yamanashi prefecture uh like a
month ago and then they had they were
trying to size their wine yeah because
of course they did and how they did that
was uh these uh they they had an a boy
Idol group that they had made to
represent all the different wines that
they were that were made there online
and I'm just like really you had to get
like France is crying right now man
[__] all of Europe is crying what
you've what have you done to our wine
man wait so there's like is like I'm
Chardonnay yeah yeah yeah
and they had made their own [__] like
anime trailer for for these boys as well
and I'm just like oh I need to see this
oh what are you doing wait let me look
it up it's just like yamanashi wine like
outside of Harajuku I don't know if it's
still there for a very long time uh in
front of the exit there was this like
anime manga panel and it looked like a
romance thing but it was advertising
password safety yes you know yes yes yes
it's like it's like a guy and a girl
texting and they're in love or something
and then it's yeah I can't remember why
but it's literally all just about
securing your passwords and it's like
what the [__] I love Yeah it literally
just if you just take a glance at it it
just looks like a panel from like a
standard Shojo romance manga right when
you look at what they're actually what
if I can find it like yeah can we find
it Abby uh the
um the uh yeah I think I remember one of
them is like the the guys doing like a
cupboard on to like the girl and the
girl's like and then the guy's like do
you want to make this relationship as
strong as your password
it's like a password
or something like that I'm just like
that is so gigabrain I love it when
they're late yeah I love it when they
like mix mix and match uh mediums and
stuff like that for advertisements
um
well there is an article on Crunchyroll
but it's blocked oh girl okay because
we're in Japan yeah right right quickly
open expressvpn yeah I think the
headline was something about Shojo manga
yeah promoting I.T safety yeah
they're all
oh oh
okay it's like hey make it's like make
sure to look after your password
oh my God
oh yeah it's like it's like I'll be
waiting until you change your password
somebody asked me they were like I was
with someone they were like what is it
what is that advert and I was like I'd
put passwords what what do you mean it's
so gigabrina I love it yeah they get
really creative with some stuff and like
really cool ways like the um that really
famous
um 3D curved advertising screen in
Shinjuku oh yeah yeah that jumps out and
they've been you know if you want that's
like their equivalent of Times Square
now yeah yeah Japan it's like if you
want the billboard that's the one yeah
yeah that's curved you do 3D it is
pretty sick when one piece red was out
they had like a whole one piece thing
playing on it where Luffy like jumps out
and there's like oh cool something I
can't remember it's like yeah that
sounds like yeah
we'd be like
screaming that's what he is literally
the Tyler one of anime
hey we should formulate a plan yeah but
uh what always interests me is like
you know sometimes seeing like the Adam
the anime tie-in like products and just
kind of seeing the lengths they will go
to with Evangelion see how they can tie
Ava into this one
very popular yeah I think the weirdest
evil one I ever saw was I think they
were advertising like horse race uh
horse race betting or something like
that and they had me they were doing
they were doing boat race spinning as
well oh really yeah because what I saw I
saw like Ava unit one as like a horse
like running it down and like gender was
betting on him I was like this is the
weirdest ass [__] I've ever seen in my
life what I love is the absolute
dichotomy it's like we will not give the
English rights to to make to license
this to anybody for 20 years oh yes go
ahead make Horseman gamble what the [__]
like we're so strict with what we give
our IP unless it's minions and uh
cleaning products and it's like what the
what the [__] why have you become super
strict about who gets to do it when it
comes to foreign people exactly having
an English adaptation like it's just
like we don't want you to ruin the image
of Eye of our IP mean meanwhile here's
what we do with our IP you know it's
just it it blows my [__] it's so like
double-sided like you see anything like
with like uh even like Nintendo right
yeah Nintendo love to be like we will we
are so stringent with rip if you go to
some arcades there are certain machines
that are Mario Party gambling machines
yeah it's basically a six player Mario
Party gambling machine where it's with
real money you you play and you try and
progress around the board to win more
money yeah it's like I'm sorry what
Nintendo like no guns in games but
gambling is cool yeah it's in Japan
you know in terms of like the image that
Japan has in terms of our advertising I
I'd say a lot of it's actually like
pretty normal it's not it's not as crazy
as what people think yeah that's what
I'm saying like there's definitely crazy
ones out there but it's certainly not
the majority because I'm I'm going to
say
in Thailand Thailand are actually
[__] amazing and making crazy ass
[__] commercials I've seen some Thai
commercials that I saw on YouTube that
are like more heart-wrenching than some
of like the most heaviest drama films
I've seen in my life there are some Thai
commercials that are just like a
two-minute short film and then it ends
and they're just like have you heard
about life insurance and I'm just like
yo you just [__] got my heart out for
life insurance for life insurance you're
working with the easiest thing to make
yeah but like but these ads are like
these ads are like like cheerio's gonna
make yourself but these ads are like
short films and and there are like so
many tie ads that don't get uploaded on
YouTube that are just weird as [__] like
I remember I'm having like a flashback
of just some of the adverts I saw as a
kid when I was in Thailand watching on
TV and I remember there was I was
watching I was in Thailand watching some
show and then it went cut to Commercial
and then it showed the scene of like a
group of uh group of like robbers or
like bank heist people
um and they had like broken into this
building yeah and they're like oh [__] I
think we got the wrong building I don't
think this is the bank and I think and
one guy goes oh I think this is like the
supermarket like there's a fridge over
there
um and so they were like what why why
why why is that all these like drinks
here have we gotten to the wrong place
and so like we started drinking it to
like try it out
and then it zooms out to be like it's a
commercial for an optician to be like
have you do you need a new prescription
for your glasses and it zooms out and
the building they've broken into is a
sperm bank
and
I'm watching that as a kid I'm just like
what is this who are you what am I
watching right now
that's so good it's like it's like some
[__] it's eating like American Pie or
something and I'm like that's that was a
weird thing to see as a kid and yeah
like go go Google some Thai commercials
because they have some wild ass [__] but
that's the thing I feel every country
has their fair share of like what the
[__] ads in the UK really yeah in
Australia for instance like there was
one ad that just stuck with me forever
it was it was an ad for a Cadbury
chocolate
um and I think it actually won like uh
like the British one like with the was
it the gorilla the gorilla one yeah that
was huge yeah that was massive yeah
everyone was like I remember when I was
a kid when that came on the TV
everyone's like everyone yeah it's a
gorilla he's playing in the air tonight
honestly that was probably that's not
the biggest the most genius ad I've seen
um yeah there's another one um I don't
know if it's British or Australian it
probably is Australian but there's a one
for uh some kind of Australian beer
um and it's this like it's this couple
that's like sleeping in the bed yeah and
the guy is just sleeping next to his
girl and whatever and his tongue starts
crawling out of his mouth
and it's like like a worm right and and
it goes like across it goes out of the
house and it crawls across the road to
this house party and goes into the
cooler grabs a beer brings it back yeah
and crawls it all the way to the guy's
mouth and then the guy wakes up with the
beer in his mouth and it's like you have
a beer and it's and it's but like at the
time the CG was so good that it was so
incredibly disturbing scene
oh like out of this guy's mouth and just
crawling around on the ground yeah oh
just [__] like that I think some some
some some adverts I remember like stand
out to me we had like the gorilla one
which was like [__] yeah that was
like huge and another one I think it was
uh ad for obviously didn't do his job
because I can't remember the product it
was selling yeah I remember the advert
itself because it had that song it was
just like
and it looked like a pretentious uh film
about surfers there was this one Surfer
um and you just hear the song in the
background
and then like the uh announcer comes on
and he just goes he waits that's what he
does
the perfect wave tick follows talk
follows tick follows top follows tick
and and it just [__] builds up and he
finds that perfect wave and I don't know
why that advert just like sticks in my
mind so much I'm pretty sure it's a
[__] beer advertisement I want to
watch it it sounds so avant-garde when
you like describe it to me what's up on
God I love uh like anti-drug commercials
as well those are fun oh he's almost
like insane
oh yeah oh of course you can forget that
legendary ad the one I think it's I
think it's an Irish ad the one where the
car it's like a drunk driving PSA yeah
the car topples over and hits like 20
kids oh yeah you've seen this one yeah
yeah that one's like whoa yeah who
thought of this one